I always find the celebrations of life
to be
trying too hard I think it's a big
mistake for people to do I know a lot of
people do it I've been to plenty of them
but I think
the funeral idea has it more correct
because death is a genuinely sad thing
and we can pretend that it's not a sad
thing we say oh well let's just
celebrate the life Let's ignore the fact
of death let's let's just focus on the
happy times but it's going to be there
you're not going to ignore that reality
Jesus wept when his friend died Jesus
wept Jesus who is Incarnate to redeem
Mankind from death and give mankind life
eternal weeps when his friend dies
moments before he raises his friend from
the dead